[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
yo.hannes what is your your role on
Amanda's team well I'm her conditioning
trainer strength coach and agility
expert you know it's my job to make sure
that she takes creatine by body by
bottle head but my father will come /op
it's it's super important to get that
you punch it
why is boxing so important to her
crossing well it's a it's a mental game
you know it's a team-building exercise
is a group effort and if she remembers
everything out there she will win
[Music]
I'm in here in the ring with her every
single day 24/7 chill win the fight for
sure rotate the shoulders here we go yep
what's your confidence level that she's
ready for the fight right now
74 have you made any changes to your
training for me down cardiovascular
health helps you towards the win that's
all you need to know
I heard a conditioning trainer a
strength coach and an agility expert
even hired a celebrity nutritionist who
has worked closely with Ronnie Coleman
Paul about diet first thing we gotta do
is protein I need to know how hard you
want to go all the way okay that's why I
like to hear all the way okay so we're
gonna go protein first so great no no no
we're not gonna start with that Ronnie
Coleman would never put this in his body
this is not going in your body but uh
I'm vegan so yeah Ronnie Coleman would
never use it so we're not gonna use I
trained Ronnie Coleman okay you pay me a
thousand dollars to trade you know we
said 500 I thought it was at first but
now when I say much work guys look at
this you look at all this this is vegan
you know I trained Ronnie Coleman can
you and so we are like we got to take
care of this we can't put this in your
body this is not work we've waived
protein I know you don't know what that
is I know that you do okay I didn't
think you knew what that was whey
protein cows chickens we need animal
proteins in you okay you know what I got
I got a better idea
Ronnie Coleman I trained him
and what have you done to prepare oh I'm
super excited I have an amazing team
beside me and everyone is so nice mmm oh
especially Bettina my nutritionist and
yes Oh BFF forever so Sam we need to
talk bad music that's why I'm here and
hopefully diet started yesterday are you
nervous
well I get butterflies in my stomach
sometimes and I also get these sharp
pings but I feel like that could
probably be from my diet basically we'll
just really drink water for 30 days
okay the competition's tomorrow sub 30
this is perfect okay and if you get
hungry blood from these oh no no no no
we're not going to eat anything and if
you get tired just go sleep I mean I
think beauty sleep is really important
and a little needed
so we'll just sleep and then you wake up
and want energy I have this
[Music]
so who are you rooting for in this fight
oh I'm rooting for Amanda
she's my daughter I'm gonna root for her
doesn't Sam your daughter too oh yeah
I'm still rooting for Amanda are you
doing listen I noticed you guys don't
have any chicken whey protein over there
oh no no we're vegan vegan okay what do
you have like off the menu I don't know
no juice in the back there we crap no I
don't think we're talking about the same
thing some gym candy No so it's in the
back thank you
ah vanilla extra protein
there you are Hey look I got all these
come on
you know protein extra proteins go eat
come on quit talking let's go oh we
gotta eat them all come on hurry up
you know all these extra protein is a
good for you let's go come on eat okay
yes keeping come on you gotta go quick
you got to eat this quick it gets right
into your blood the more than the
fascinated the more protein you get in
there the better you're gonna feel
okay come on okay you're doing good okay
come on that's perfect that's perfect
that's exactly how it's supposed to feel
when you're getting extra protein eat
eat come on faster I need you to eat
faster I need you to train harder I need
you better I need more from you I need
much more hurry eat that Ronnie call me
water finish these bands twenty minutes
ago so what do you think about this
fight I don't know too much about it um
but I've heard I mean I've seen that
she's been training Hampton so Christina
how do you know Sam I know we're from
around town we I've come in and gotten
some drinks for her at the bee I love
her who do you think is gonna win I
think Sam my money's on Sam's I think
she's going she's gonna pull through and
what do you guys think
I totally thinks a serious girl it yeah
why how do you know and I love and I
want to wish
feel the burn team no tan line
so you're training both of the girls is
there a conflict of interest there well
I don't see any conflict with that
[Music]
is there any differences in how you're
training each of the girls yeah
absolutely they have different body
types so obviously the thought chaining
routine needs to be differently
especially for Sam like she needs you
know more flexibility than than Amanda
knows yeah
extend your arms fully fully extend your
arms get better in better
we're not done with the workout workout
what's the key to success with Samantha
Oh hydration is key especially with the
water bottle it's very important Sam
what's your prediction for the fight
well I feel like I'm fully ready for
anything that comes my way and oh yeah
and also my Colina sponsored by Gaston
Dolce Gabanna
what do you put Samantha's odds of
winning the fight 12
what is your opponent's weakness well
she is trying way too hard
Vogue magazine says that effortless
beauty always wins the fight always wins
the fight
so a minute how do you feel I'm very
confident in what I do I know my
component I know its technique tell you
right now step by step is gonna happen
it's gonna come at me fearing its untain
moves they're gonna leave it off balance
it's pure it's gonna get in in space and
it's nothing to see the comet and the
boat one strikes for this temple
immediate chaos you said component did
you mean opponent no I said opponent
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so what just happened now he's just
going for a walk and I just see these
two just kind of going at it and uh man
it was just crazy said I had to jump in
and get him Oh what happened to you guys
well okay one so tense Ernie no no I
seem certain you know Amanda I'm one and
all I'm one the whole thing
[Music]